hello guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Selena
my social eanes back on the channel and
I thought what better way to bring
someone back on than checking out some
more vines this got sent to me by
several people the new best vines 2014
funniest Thomas Sanders vine
compilation' I am not familiar with
Thomas Sanders I want to get more
familiar with vines cuz we're suddenly
do more vines to get a vine
I actually do I like the rearmost yeah
mines are awesome so let's check out
this compilation the only compilation I
check out is onna no porn
there she is she's so beautiful yeah
she's so hot well throughout the
compilation I just imagine her little
time to act like all her yeah whatever
but I imagine the guys to be the real
guys in the video so that's doing stuff
with her yeah so where are you off to
I'm on my way to steal your girl now get
me some jumping jacks let's watch out
real food Disney gee you do up my group
where is your project uh right here
whoopee hey on sale you guys selling
yards what I want your yard what
what is happening I don't know I just
don't get people I can't talk to them
right you understand me sassy Lassie get
over here you're welcome samatha we
usually just go commando really yeah
don't stop believin about to see
Annabelle I'm not scared
later please you can't eat food what's
your reader let's go I'm ready
nice to meet you ready I'm dad you mM
understand this any questions yes like
each one has 26 parts why time to
download later download complete
so we story time the man was about to
step on a snake but a snake but he
missed it
alright kids nothing to be afraid of say
goodbye to the house kids
now they all know hey can you check up
the milk went bad yeah I should reward
myself healthy no dude who wants to eat
fight freakin crime I was looking for
Sasaki
Disney bring some friends hey anyone can
cook and now 24/7 Christmas music
Halloween was yesterday Christmas
Pikachu go hey hey what's up you Sean
enemy was confused holiday time for bed
dear school tomorrow what what we've
been seen I'm miss so what hey what do
you think of the new shirt it's nice it
distract me from your face oh yeah they
want your skin me jeans because your
booty be poppin ha ha ha
turn up story huh she did been waiting
her whole life for someone to sweep her
off her feet
story time the ladies congregate here
everyday to scope out the hot dudes ha
joke time nope nope there it's your best
friend Stewie Griffin and he's always
gonna be there for you you want to pass
get something yep are you sure yes are
you sure no correct you have cooties
it's a joke it's like dude mr. myko
nothing that's right oh yeah Oh who's
ready for a new week of learning
sorry no he's here story time the lad
decided to do the honorable thing and
share his treat with mother - we're
friends this is snake in my boot Reese
Joey I got you now you stabbed him
well I got your wallet what what the
look at your backup Oh beautiful and now
the Sun is coming out bathroom hurry
back
you got big ears you have big teeth you
have
you are my least favorite grandchild
yeah this is nice all right now let's
bury you Disney braixen with friends
often I turn the lights open surprise
Lily all right Stewie Brian you're
perfect you're perfect
monopoly guys sure I the racecar nice
dating you
she's skip young me and we're gonna live
under this roof you're gonna live under
these rules first off look welcome to
Vegas for you ready go to TV and watch
your favorite show good job yeah where
ever was in a dream world like you were
there like Mike was there great on the
stereo brace yourselves
winter is coming
Thank You Stuart is that the other bread
tender kiss Oh
valium help deadly to find me
I will pancakes he's right here do you
want to talk to him
he's right here so much candy so much
candy won't you stay with me
Disney pranks with friends blue punch
buggy what was that dude what was that
hunter know how about I make you dinner
tonight
really Bon Appetit would you like
pepperonis and cheese what story time
the man's butt scratching wasn't
complete dude what it is delightful true
what okay cuz I must must say something
crazy I'm not crazy dad do you learn a
bad thing and fun then it's crazy
let me finish each other's - here's your
gift I am living in the lap of luxury
no you're living in the streets I'm
sorry what was your name luxury oh yeah
are you kidding me it's only midnight
it's so early
I know those that stumble and those that
ball must pay the rice just of a part
may God have mercy on you now honey
there's nothing under your bed you've
got nothing to be afraid something moved
I always say good night to me go save
yourself Jigglypuff go use John Oh
dress code orange do we say mama no mama
no
my anaconda tent won't know now what are
you gonna do with your life go what do
you want to do your life be a dancer the
man knew exactly what to do bare is his
son ha ha ha
try faster oh that's right a rabbi good
man
I've never seen him before he was really
funny is he really the voice of Stewie
no it's not the voice of Stewie that's
the creator of Family Guy well ok he has
a damn good impression really is a
really good impression awesome I feel
like he has a lot of fun at school
yeah he's able to it looks like he's
getting his teachers on board the police
officer yeah he seems kinda he knows how
to use his elders too for fun videos all
right it's Polly's grandpa very creative
Grampa very creative like this I've seen
a lot of these vine videos but that was
probably the funniest compilation I've
seen that was good yeah pretty cool
which one's your favorite um it has to
be this guy actually I like I like Bo
Burnham a lot I mean he's not really a
finer buddy
I love his vines the most what was your
favorite vine of he's know if his let me
do laughing um good question yeah I'm
not sure which one the one I really
remember though is Sean Bean from Game
of Thrones oh yeah that was pretty cool
that he was able to get him in have that
video I think this guy's very treat him
and I love his personality and Sanders
he's probably Jewish probably probably
watches uh Jewish porn compilations
maybe are you gonna make this race Oh
what is the matter dad comes in a girl
oh I am ah typical Jewish a typical
Jewish gym well anyway guys thanks for
tuning in if you guys are new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out Selena's
channel she's going with that [ __ ] and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter where if we get enough
followers we
you can get product placement that's
right people for things such as wellness
formula wellness formula is great if you
ever feel sick you can take some
wellness formula if your sperm count is
running low you can take some wellness
formula chelina come back for that
sometimes her sperm count is very low so
she takes wellness formula that's right
people Qiu Lina has a penis
unfortunately I know this hate it why
why do we have to go there why'd you
show it to me
oh you wellness formula